la pologne qui à ce jour en moins de
trois semaines a reçu plus de 1,4
million de réfugiés
venus d'ukraine ils sont arrivés
notamment ici à medica à la frontière
entre la pologne et l'ukraine vous le
voyez derrière moi les conditions ici
sont celles d'une véritable crise
humanitaire il y a des centaines de
personnes qui arrivent ici chaque jour
elle arrivait à pied elles arrivent en
voiture elles sont exténués par leur
voyage vous voyez derrière moi des bus
des ambulances vous voyez que ces bustes
à sont là pour les acheminer vers des
centres d'hébergement d'urgence les
ambulances sont là pour traiter les cas
les cas sévères les personnes blessées
les personnes en état de choc puisque a
énormément qui sont choqués par le
voyage choqué par ce qu'elles ont vécu
choquée d'avoir finalement tout perdu
l'office internationale pour les
migrations oim est également présent ici
un peu plus loin vous le voyez aussi
derrière moi c'est en ces temps
d'hébergement provisoire ici à la
frontière polonaise ou y fait un froid
glacial il fait -6 degrés aujourd'hui
sachant que les températures vont encore
baisser dans des conditions vraiment
très très très très sévère pour cette
cette crise humanitaire qui continue de
se développer c'est à la frontière
question peut-être emmanuel on a vu
l'élan solidarité 1 au sein des nombreux
pays membres de l'europe ces derniers
jours certains ont même pris leur
véhicule personnel pour se rendre
directement à cette frontière est livré
une aide une aide humanitaire beaucoup
de vêtements de la nourriture des
médicaments mais il semblerait qu'ils
restent bloqués à la frontière qu'est ce
qu'il en est exactement
alors écoutez ici à la frontière
polonaise je vois beaucoup des ong qui
ont pu faire le déplacement qui peuvent
également passer il ya des pompiers
volontaires français il ya également des
individus des personnes qui est juste à
titre individuel vienne qui ont fait des
récoltes des collectes d'argent des
collègues de vêtements qui les dépose
ici vous voyez derrière moi certaines de
ces collectes et vous voyez les gens
passer ici ce sont surtout des femmes
des enfants des personnes âgées beaucoup
de gens aussi sont venus avec leurs
animaux de compagnie ici et puis vous
l'avez mentionné il ya un énorme élan de
solidarité qui qui a pris place
finalement à travers toute l'europe mais
ici en pologne c'est ça se voit
particulièrement énormément polonais ont
ouvert leur maison le gouvernement
polonais a développé 8 milliards de
zlotys ça fait environ 1 bien que 6
milliards d'euros environ 7 milliards de
dollars de fonds d'urgence pour aider
aux déplacements pour aider à ces
populations déplacées venus d'ukraine la
pologne qui avaient déjà une très forte
population ukrainienne de près de deux
millions d'habitants avant le début de
l'invasion russe alors j'ai pu j'ai pu
parler avec certains polonais qui disait
que c'est sans doute pour cette raison
que ça sera pas trop difficile pour les
ukrainiens nouvellement arrivées de
s'intégrer dans la société polonaise
ceux par exemple il ya beaucoup de sites
administratifs qui sont déjà traduit en
ukrainien mais comme vous le voyez
autour de moi en attendant ça reste une
situation d'urgence une situation qui ne
s'améliore pas au contraire et des
infrastructures humanitaires comme vous
pouvez voir autour de moi qui sont
encore bien sommaire par rapport au
nombre de personnes qui arrivent tous
les jours ici